man when you look at the numbers they're
very very clear in 2019 and we'll go to
2020 so far but in 2019 there were nine
african-american people shot who are
unarmed most people can put two and two
together and realize that just because
you're unarmed don't mean you're not a
threat don't mean that it's unjustified
but for the sake of arguing just say
that all nine unarmed black males were
killed by police unjustifiably there is
44 million black people I have lost
count of the zeros and the percentage of
you getting killed by a police officer
unjustifiably and when you look at those
numbers and then you go and you look at
the amount of black people who get
killed on a day-to-day basis through
black on black violence and you do not
see the same level of outrage the same
level of protest we can clearly see that
is some brainwashing going on since I
think everyone watching this probably
agrees with that I mean any sensible
person we want justice to be served
obviously they've been taken into
custody and hopefully the system will
deal with them appropriately so we have
to shift to now what's becoming the the
bigger story here so as the guy that
co-founded blogs it with Candice Owens
it seems to me that you guys have made
just absolutely staggering amounts of
traction in terms of waking up black
people - you don't have to be a Democrat
which is just a simple fact of the world
your skin color of course should not
dictate what political party you are so
first let me just start let's let's just
start with that how is that just
connected to all of this the narrative
that we're seeing right now that America
is racist and that policing is racist
and it's systemic and that our founding
is racist how is all of that stuff
connected to why you guys wanted to
start blogs it yeah because when you
think about it for what it is it's like
we are outraged we are burning built
burning down communities protesting and
rioting days in day in and day out for
what
and what I have observed and cannons are
like well we have observed is that we
have been brainwashed into thinking with
our emotions and not thinking with facts
man when you look at the numbers they're
very very clear in 2019 and we'll go to
2020 so far but in 2019 there were nine
african-american people shot who are
unarmed most people can put two and two
together and realize that just because
you're unarmed don't mean you're not a
threat don't mean that it's unjustified
but for the sake of arguing just say
that all non unarmed black males were
killed by police unjustifiably there is
44 million black people I have lost
count of the zeros and the percentage of
you getting killed by a police officer
unjustifiably and when you look at those
numbers and then you go and you look at
the amount of black people who get
killed on a day-to-day basis through
black on black violence and you do not
see the same level of outrage the same
level of protest we can clearly see that
it's some brainwashing going on and what
Candis and I want to do is just outfit
people with the truth and give them an
outlet to say I don't have to just think
and be ignorant just because I'm black I
can have an open mind I can see what's
really going on some of these people
live in the hood some of these people
know that they're not afraid of the
police they know that they're afraid of
gang violence and abuse that happens in
the inner city a lot of people know that
it has something to do with social
economic status and not just necessarily
the color of your skin so we are pushing
truth and initially it hurts man a lot
of people hate us initially they don't
want to hear from us with kun sellout
Uncle Tom's but as time goes along and
they can see that there's a BS narrative
being pushed they can see that that
black people are destroying their own
communities that it is gotten out of
control
they begin to see people like myself and
Candice who are promoting facts and they
begin to wake up it's simple mathematics
so I got to bring up a guy who I know
you know and I know you saw this moment
when larry elder beat me senseless with
that moves me up woke me up to so much
of this stuff right but what do you do
with a certain set of people who don't
respond to facts because even on
Twitter for the last 24 hours I tried to
take the weekend off it didn't work that
well but just in the last 24 hours of
being on Twitter I see the type of stuff
that you are putting out there I see the
type of stuff that a lot of
conservatives are putting out there
relative to facts and numbers and all of
these things and I never see any counter
to those things generally by people on
the Left I see the sort of overly
emotional you know we just we are a
racist because in and of itself it is
true it's just it's self-evident that
were a racist nation so what do you do
when a certain set of people won't
accept facts well I go with the Bible
man I mean Jesus was preaching truth in
fact and they killed him and so my thing
is that we need to just continue to
promote facts and truth and understand
that we are planting seeds not every
single person is going to turn around
every time we open our mouth and say
something but we have to be consistent
with what we know to be true just like
Jesus even though they killed him he was
raised on the third day and now he's the
most talked about person ever in history
the Bible is the most sold book in the
history of the world so we have to
continue to stick with the mission keep
your own facts and understand that we're
planting seeds and at some point those
seeds will be watered and one of the
reasons why we can do that is because
Candace and I are a product of seeds
being planted like you said Larry elder
and others planet seeds in us and then
in 2016 the perfect storm of enough
water and sunshine sprouted up seeds
that are now some of the most impactful
individuals in the black movement no I
mean it's been unbelievable just to see
this thing grow it's it's just you know
I tweeted out about a year ago in the
midst of one of these stories that
Trump's gonna get something like 30% of
the black vote and of course you know
nobody wants to be in the prediction
game and I had a lot of blue cheque
lefties really angry at me for saying it
and of course everything right now it's
like who the hell knows what's gonna
happen but I think you guys have made a
dent and whether that dent is fully
evident in this coming election or it's
the one after or the one after it just
seems obvious but but let's move to sort
of be immediacy right now because it
seems to me this is no longer about
George Floyd I mean when you're watching
people
burned down stores break into liquor
shops loot the Nike store tear down a
target all of the rest of it what what
do you think the transition is from a
righteous cause of not wanting to see in
an you know someone be killed unjustly
to where we're at right now like how
many steps does that take and do you
think some of this was pre-planned
before it all began just a couple days
ago yeah I think man I think it's a lot
of people in our society that are just
described there's a lot of people who
didn't get parent well there's a lot of
people that just want violence they
don't want justice they want revenge
they have been brainwashed they don't
want to go to work they don't want to
work hard they don't believe in the
American Dream they hate this country to
hate themselves and those people tend to
flare up when we have incidents like
this because clearly they are not
focused on George Floyd they're not
focused on police brutality police
brutality has nothing to do with
footlocker and Louie Vuitton and Gucci
it has nothing to do with stealing and
burning down historical buildings has
nothing to do with that the man was
arrested it should be over the protest
should be over the looting the rioting
the outrage should be done with but it's
not so we need to understand that there
is a difference between individuals who
are actually wanting something to change
and then the individuals who are burning
stuff down because they're brats and
they're just minutes to society and
those two parties end up clashing
because politicians and other liberal
and I say leftist black talking hands
won't be honest they're coming out
saying that it's antifa and they're and
they're just completely forgetting or
trying to evade the fact that there are
black lives matter individuals involved
in this as well
so we need to take a tough stance and
law enforcement we need to start using
force against individuals who are out
here burning people's property and
putting people's lives at danger and
then we also need to have the rhetoric
from President Trump and other quality
leaders who are saying enough is enough
we're gonna deal with police brutality
but this is not the way to do it you
know you mentioned the political leaders
and it's like well Minnesota and
Minneapolis everyone involved every
public official is a Democrat
every public official is a Democrat this
thing has nothing to do with Trump
doesn't mean that Trump's reaction has
been perfect that's a separate issue but
every time this happens in one of these
cities in Atlanta in Ferguson wherever
might be we find out that they're
Democrat run cities so to that end or
when you hear de Blasio in New York City
who doesn't you know he lets criminals
out of jail and then tells them that you
know if you jump turnstiles you won't
even get a citation or anything like
that do you think in many ways the ship
has already sailed like how can they
reset it you know I've talked to some
people at the NYPD over the last couple
months they've had it with the
leadership but I think they don't
exactly know what to do because you know
they are civil servants still but they
know that their leaders are not allowing
them to restore law and order yeah I
think the citizens are waking up there
even with the Koch kovat epidemic and
I'll let going on you can see most of
the liberal mayors the liberal governors
they want people shut down forever they
don't want you to ever work again they
want you to be they want to destroy your
businesses and people were able to see
that with Kovac and now you look at the
cities that are getting burned down
these liberal mayors and governors won't
even contest these individuals people's
businesses are getting burned to the
ground
they're never coming back the reputation
of the city is completely tarnished
they're willing to put you in jail for
not wearing a mask or not social
distancing but they're letting people go
have a free-for-all if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell